Bitte schön.
Hallo. Guten Abend.
Polat ist mein Name. Ich bin auf dieser Station Al-Fashtan.
Erstin tätig. Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen ein Anamese-Gespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Ja.
Okay. Bevor wir über Ihre aktuelle Anamese sprechen,
möchte ich zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten erfahren.
Ja.
Wie heißt es?
Ich heiße Bettina Schneiderait.
Bettina WC, oder?
Bettina mit 2T, ja. Bettina.
Können Sie bitte Ihre Nachmarschung stabilen?
Ja, Schneiderait schreibt sich SCH-N-E-I-D-E-R.
Ja.
Bettina Schneiderait.
Frau Schneiderait.
Wie heißt es?
26.
Am 14. April 1996.
Wie viel wiegt es?
63 kg.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 m.
Alles klar.
Frau Schneiderait, was für die Beschwerden haben Sie?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ja, seit fünf Tagen habe ich bemerkt,
dass in der linken Kniekehle eine Rötung ist,
die auch etwas juckt.
Diese Rötung ist größer geworden in den letzten Tagen.
Seit heute habe ich auch Schmerzen in der linken Leiste.
Haben diese Beschwerden plötzlich angefangen
oder eher langsam?
Langsam.
Okay.
Haben Sie dabei Schmerzen?
Ja, in der Leiste tut es weh.
Wenn ich dahin drücke, da sind so etwas so Knubbel in der Leiste.
Wie so Knoten.
Linken Leiste.
Schmerzhaft.
Ja.
Okay, alles klar.
Gibt es bestimmte Auslöser,
die diese Schmerzen ausgelöst werden?
Ja, wenn ich z.B. drauf drücke oder eine enge Hose trage,
dann kann ich nicht gut.
Eine Jeans drückt zu sehr in der Leiste.
Und in der Kniekehle ist es auch etwas geschwollen.
Und ich kann auch das Knie nicht ganz strecken,
nicht ganz durchdrücken.
Das tut hinten auf weh.
Ja, haben Sie den Knie gut beugen?
Beugen kann ich es ganz gut,
aber am Ende glaube ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Aber es spannt etwas.
Es ist allgemein, da ist, ja, das ist nicht in Ordnung,
weil es so rot ist und auch juckt.
Das heißt, fühlt sich das da an etwas überwärmt.
Okay.
Haben Sie, als Sie früher schon einmal in Leiste beschwerden?
Nein, sowas habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas eingenommen oder etwas gemacht?
Ich habe gestern etwas gekühlt mit einer Eispackung.
Das hat etwas geholfen,
aber eben die Rötung ist seit gestern noch größer geworden.
Ja, haben Sie die Kühlanwendung in der Leichsdereich angewöhnt?
Nur in der Kniekele.
Die leistenschmerzen habe ich erst seit heute Morgen.
Okay, alles klar.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass in Ihrer Kniekele etwas Insekts gebissen hat?
Das kann sein.
In der Mitte von dieser Rötung, da ist so eine Stelle.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ob das ein Biss, ein Stich oder ein Biss ist.
Ja, es ist so eine kleine, wie eine Kruste.
Aber trotzdem haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass in Mitte roten gibt es etwas.
Ja, da ist so eine dunkle Stelle, aber ich habe keinen Stich bemerkt.
Wenn sonst etwas sticht wie eine Wespe oder eine Biene, das tut sehr weh.
Aber das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Sind Sie in der Leichsdereich im Kalt gegangen?
Vor einer Woche habe ich eine Wanderung gemacht über mehrere Stunden.
Da habe ich ein Picknick gemacht auf einer Wiese.
Okay, alles klar.
Frau Schneider, haben Sie bemerkt, dass Sie Fieber haben?
Die Stelle, die hinten fühlt sich sehr warm an, sehr heiß an.
Aber Fieber glaube ich habe ich nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Nachschweiß oder Karlsinnschweiß?
Nein.
Haben Sie in der Leichsdereich ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe immer mein Gewicht gehalten in den letzten Jahren.
Okay, alles gut.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masse-Lassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein, habe ich immer alles in Ordnung.
Ist Ihnen übel?
Da mussten Sie sich übergeben?
Nein, keine Übelkeit und kein Erbrechen.
Okay, alles gut.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten ein oder durchzuschlafen?
Ich mache jetzt bald Examen.
Da habe ich manchmal Schlafprobleme,
weil ich mir sehr viele Gedanken mache wegen dem Examen.
Das habe ich gut verstanden.
Das kann ich gut verstehen.
Das heißt, Sie sind Studierende.
Ja, ich studiere Jura.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein.
Alles klar.
Frau Schneider, Sie haben Schmerz-Haffte-Lymphknoten
in der linken Leichte bemerkt.
Ja, das sind so Knobbeln.
Sind das Lymphknoten?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Es sind so Knobbeln in der Leiste.
Knobbeln.
Aber haben Sie in anderen Bereichen bemerkt?
Nein, nur in der Leiste.
Okay.
Frau Schneider, leiden Sie an irgendwelche chronischen Erkrankungen?
Ich nehme wegen einer vergrößerten Schilddrüse
und einer Unterfunktion ein Schilddrüsen-Medikament ein,
seit zehn Jahren.
Welche Medikamente nehmen Sie?
Das heißt, Ältüroxin 50.
Okay, wie oft nehmen Sie?
Einmal morgens.
Gibt es noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ich habe etwas Heuschnupfen, so im Frühjahr, Birke und Gräser.
Ich nehme manchmal etwas Phenistil-Tabletten.
Vor dem Sport, ich jogge gerne, nehme ich dann auch mal Spre.
Aber nur über einen Zeitraum von drei, vier Wochen,
dann ist das weg.
Dann die Pollen nicht mehr fliegen.
Ja, in diesem Zeitraum,
welchen Medikament nehmen Sie?
Ich habe nicht gut verstanden.
Phenistil?
Ja, und der Spre heißt Salbutamol.
Okay, ist klar.
Ist bei Ihnen außer Heuschnupfen,
ganz weich aller Gehen oder Unfälligkeit bekannt?
Nein, nichts mehr.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich bin vollständig geimpft.
Ich war vor drei Jahren, war ich mal in Afrika
und habe da alle Impfungen bekommen, Hepatitis,
Tethanus, Difterie, Gelbfieber,
habe drei Impfungen, ich habe eigentlich alle Impfungen.
Super.
Sie haben eben erwähnt,
ich glaube, sie war im Ausland gewesen.
Ja, aber schon vor drei Jahren.
Okay, waren Sie in den,
letztes Jahr im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Frau Schneiderath,
haben Sie regelmäßige Periode?
Ja.
Nehmen Sie Pille?
Nein.
Das ist ein, dass Sie schwanger sind?
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Nein, das halte ich unwahrscheinlich.
Alles klar.
Rauchen Sie Schneiderath?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Super.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ja, aber sehr unregelmäßig.
Mal auf einer Feier.
Das ist aber vielleicht ein bis zweimal im Monat trinke ich
vielleicht ein Glas Wein.
Aber das ist unregelmäßig.
Verstanden.
Nehmen Sie sonstige Droge?
Nein.
Frau Schneiderath, Sie sind Jurastudentin.
Und sind Sie verreiartet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Leben Sie alleine oder mit Ihrer Familie?
Nein, ich lebe alleine.
Okay.
Auf Sie haben erwähnt, dass Sie regelmäßig Sport treiben?
Ja, ich mache regelmäßig Sport.
Ich jogge dreimal die Woche und zweimal in der Woche fahre ich Rennrad.
Ja, super.
Ist in Ihrer Familie oder in Ihrer Eltern
ein jütes chronischer Erkrankungsbekann?
Ja, ich bin ein jütes chronischer Erkrankungsbekann.
Mein Vater, der ist 56 Jahre alt,
hat schon eine Hüftartrose.
Und er soll auch bald operiert werden,
weil das ist schon sofort geschritten, aber er möchte noch warten.
Er wurde operiert?
Nein, der Orthopäde rät ihm dazu, sich operieren zu lassen.
Aber mein Vater möchte noch warten.
Ja, klar.
Ihre Mutter gibt es bestimmt?
Meine Mutter ist 55 Jahre alt und die ist gesund.
Ja, super.
Haben Sie eine Schwester?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Schwester,
die hat auch mit der Schildrüse Probleme
und nimmt auch ein Schildrüsenmedikament.
Meinen Sie Unterfunktion?
Ja, eine leichte Unterfunktion und auch eine leichte Vergrößerung der Schildrüse.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, frage Schneiderad.
Ich möchte nur eine letzte Frage stellen.
In der linken Kniekehle oder in der Oberschenkel
haben Sie bemerkt, dass Taubheit gefühlt oder kriebeln?
Nein, das ist nur in der linken Kniekehle,
ist das so etwas gespannt und gerötet und etwas heiß.
Und in der linken Leiste tut das weh,
und da sind diese, ich nenne sie jetzt bald Knubbel oder Knoten.
Und haben Sie bemerkt, dass Ihre Unterchenkel
oder Ihre Fußschwählungen haben?
Nein, sonst nicht geschwahl.
Alles klar.
Meinesseits habe ich eine wichtige Frage gestellt,
Frau Schneiderad,
möchten Sie etwas miszufügen oder haben Sie noch Fragen?
Ja, ich frage natürlich, was kann das sein?
Aber das werden Sie ja vielleicht feststellen,
wenn Sie mich untersuchen und das anschauen.
Aber ich möchte gerne, dass das jetzt natürlich besser wird,
weil diese Schmerzen in der Leiste,
die sind schon ganz schön stark, wenn ich da drauf drücke.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, aber leider kann ich gerade nichts genau sagen.
Ich um eine Diagnose festzustellen,
müssen wir körperliche Untersuchungen
und diagnostische Massnahmen durchführen.
Wenn ich alle Ergebnisse bekomme,
werde ich Sie darüber am laufenden Halten.
Okay, gut.
Können wir so machen?
Nehmen Sie im Wartesraum ein Platz,
dann mache ich Sie wieder auf.
Danke, machen wir so.
Gut.
Dann machen wir fünf Minuten.
Haben Kollegen andere Fragen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen, aber nicht nützlich.
Aber ich möchte Fragen.
Wie ist das mit Schmerzen auf einer Skala,
klassische Frage?
Können Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind Sie hoch und drückend, stehend, kussierend?
Wenn ich drauf drücke, ist ein Druckschmerz.
Dann drückt das.
Wenn ich gar nichts mache und nur ruhig liege,
dann tut das nicht so weh.
Aber wenn ich drauf drücke oder dran komme,
dann ist es sehr schmerzhaft.
Was meinen Sie denn?
Was soll ich für eine Skala sagen?
Auf der nummerischen Skala von 1 bis 10,
wobei 1 sehr leicht und 10 sehr stark Schmerzen erschienen.
Okay.
Wenn ich da drauf drücke, dann kann das schon 6 sein, 6 bis 7.
Dankeschön.
Aber es ist kein Dauerschmerz, nur wenn ich Kontakt habe.
Ich sehe, ob das nicht offen ist,
oder nur eine kleine Knie ist.
Nein, das ist nicht offen.
Nur in der Mitte ist so eine kleine Kruste.
Die ist aber ganz klein, die ist so vielleicht so groß wie ein Streichholzkopf.
Größer ist die nicht.
Eine etwas dunkle Stelle.
Können wir anfangen, Nala?
Nehmen wir ein paar Minuschen.
Okay.
Ich komme sofort.
Ich bin nicht sicher.
Scheidenausfluss.
Das kommt hier akustisch nicht so gut an.
Okay, Scheidenausfluss.
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Lieber und Stellfluss gefragt hat.
Ja, genau.
Ja.
Schön.
Können wir?
Ja.
Okay.
Guten Abend, Herr Oberant.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patientin aufgenommen.
Ich möchte Ihnen vorstellen.
Die Patientin heißt Bettina Schneider-Reit.
Sie ist 26 Jahre alt.
Am 14.04.1996 gebogen.
Sie ist 63 kg schwer und 1,74 m groß.
Wir haben eine Patientin, die sich bei uns aufgenommen hat.
Sie ist 26 Jahre alt.
Wir haben eine Patientin, die sich bei uns seit 5 Tagen bestehende.
Wir haben eine Überwärmung und Schwellung in der linken Kniekehle vor.
Linkspopulitär.
Okay.
Gibt es noch weitere Symptome bei der Patientin?
Ja, genau.
Auch die Patientin bestätigt,
dass heute Morgen eine schmerzhafte Knobel in der linken Leiste bemerkt.
Ja.
An was denken Sie da?
Was kann das sein?
Schmerzen in der linken Leiste und mit Knobeln?
Das ist ein Liftknot.
Ja, eine Lymphadenitis.
Ja, linksadenitis in der linken Leiste.
Ja, okay.
Hat die Patientin Fieber Schöttelfrost?
Nein, Fieber und Stuflöse und Fragner Fieber und Stuflöse
und Stuflöse.
Ja, die Patientin.
Vor ein Wochen
seien die Patientin in Wanderung gewandert.
Ja.
Anomnistisch gibt die Patientin an,
vor einer Woche gewandert zu sein.
Hat die Patientin noch etwas Besonderes gemacht?
Ja, sie hätte Picnic gemacht.
Auf einer Wiese.
Okay.
Ja, das kann natürlich schon eine diagnostische Hilfestellung sein.
Hat die Patientin eine sichtbare Lymphangitis?
Ja, sie beschreiben ja eine Rötung und Schwellung linkspopliteal
und eine Lymphadenitis linksinlinal.
Sie ist auch Zeichen einer Lymphangitis auf der Haut?
Ja, sie berichtet, dass sie Schmerzen und Überwärmung...
Okay, gut.
Also eine Lymphangitis kann man ja eigentlich nur sehen,
wie soell, auf der Haut.
Oft sieht man sie ja nicht.
Oft sind nur die Lymphknoten gespollen.
Okay, gibt es etwas Aufhelliges in der Vorgeschichte der Patientin?
Vorgeschichte.
Ja, die Patientin nannte Hypothyroidis.
Ja.
Sie hat Hypothyroidis.
Ja, hat die Patientin eine Stroma?
Ja, Stroma.
Also eine Stroma-Diffuser mit Hypothyriose.
Sie hat das Behandelt?
Ja, dagegen nehmen die Patientin Level-Truxesin 50 Milligramm ein.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es in der Familie Auffälligkeiten?
Ihre Mutter leidet an Proxatros.
Ja, okay.
Ihre Mutter ist gesund.
Okay, gut.
Und gibt es Geschwister?
Ja, ihre Geschwister leidet an Hypothyroidis auch.
Okay, gut.
Was ist Ihre Verdachtdiagnose?
Nach besetter Angabe gehe ich
mit einem Verdacht auf Borreliose aus.
Borreliose hat eins mit Eritema Migrans.
Eritema Migrans, genau.
Internet berichtet, dass die Rötung zunimmt.
Ja.
Also ein Eritema Migrans mit Begleit Lymphadenitis links in Gwinal.
Und das ist eine, wie Sie das Schildern treffen,
eine Verdachtdiagnose sein.
Ja.
Was wollen Sie jetzt noch diagnostisch machen?
Ja, zuerst werde ich körperlich untersuchen,
ob diese publikal Bereich und in Gwinal bereits Wunde
oder irgendwelche Wisten gibt.
Dann nehme ich Blut ab.
Bei der Laboruntersuchung bestimme ich Entzündungszeichen.
Gut.
Blutbild auch.
Und Sereologie, glaube ich, wurde ich durchführen.
Eine Borreliensereologie ist wahrscheinlich im Akutstadion noch nicht
aussagekräftig, weil oft die Borreliensereologie nachhängt,
also einige Tage später erst positiv wird.
Es wäre ein Trugschluss, wenn die Negativ ist,
dass man sagt, das ist keine Borreliose.
Die Vorgeschichte werden oft nach makroskopischen visuellen Kriterien
erst diagnostiziert.
Die Vorgeschichte kann dafür sprechen.
Die Wanderung, das hat der Aufenthalt auf der Wiese.
Es ist zurzeit Borrelgenzeit.
Im Winter wäre das eher weniger wahrscheinlich.
Aber der klinische Aspekt ist da schon entscheidend.
Die Rötung, die Wanderröte.
Und die Überwärmung, vielleicht lokal.
Und dann auch noch die Lymphadenitis.
Das alles kann für eine Borreliose gerade eins sprechen.
Und die würde man dann bei diesem Befund dann doch antibiotisch behandeln.
Genau.
Okay.
Gut.
Aus meiner Sicht ist das in Ordnung.
Lassen Sie sich nicht aus der Ruhe bringen.
Aber Sie bleiben Sie bei Ihrem Stema.
Und Sie haben, denke ich, schon sich bemüht,
die medizinischen Fachausdrücke auch zu sozusagen zu bringen.
Ich habe jetzt extra bewusst mal zwar einen einfachen Fall genommen,
aber mit durchaus vielen medizinischen Fachausdrücken.
Und da gehört dann eben rein,
Verdacht auf Borreliose gerade eins nach Zeckenbiss vor einigen Tagen
mit Ihre Thema Migrants und Begleit Lymphadenitis links in Green All.
Dann vermeiden Sie bitte linke Leiste,
sondern dann bitte, wenn es geht, links in Green All.
Wie ist das in Farbe?
Ist das gut?
Ist das in Ordnung?